Teen Titans go it's a cartoon for kids
right wrong not all episodes are for
young viewers there's some pretty
inappropriate stuff in this show here
are 10 teen titans go episodes that
weren't for kids you're not going to
believe the crazy stuff this show got
away with four number one if you like
Teen Titans go as much as we do
subscribe to the things channel to get
more videos dishing out the good stuff
on all things Teen Titans like this
video hit the thumbs up Pirate Booty
going on a date as a teen can be
downright intimidating and confusing at
that age young people are learning about
boundaries consent and appropriate
versus inappropriate behavior the last
thing they need is a cartoon suggesting
that a person should expose himself on a
date well that's what this Teen Titans
go episode did when Raven says she is
ready to go out on a date with Aqualad
cyborg makes a pretty inappropriate joke
for young years he asks Raven if Aqualad
has shown her his pirate booty yet Raven
chuckles at this dirty joke before
saying no this is probably the wrong
message to send to the youth of America
it's one that implies it's okay for
teens to show some booty on dates of
course we know that the definition of
pirate booty is treasure such as money
and jewels obtained by pirates from
plundering and pillaging but we think
kids might take it to mean something
else so rule number one kids keep your
booty in your boat and maybe no
plundering or pillaging either actually
just don't go in any dates after
watching this cartoon and definitely
don't take advice on social etiquette
from cyborg but mostly keep your booty
to yourself lady legasus Raven gets
creative with her legs after the Titans
take her cloak away as a joke
she dubs herself lady legasus then she
is openly ogled and is told that she is
more open and free without her clothes
is that a thinly veiled message to girls
so they are better people when they wear
less clothing Raven decides to have some
fun with her unclothed legs and goes on
a bad guy fighting spree using several
unconventional leg techniques the one
that caught our attention as being
pretty inappropriate was this scissor
slice you see kids when adults say women
are doing the scissor technique they are
probably talking about well that usually
mean
know what forget it we're going to leave
that one alone we hope kids get a kick
out of this episode we didn't mean to
tap-dance around this uncomfortable
subject this scene made us pretty weak
in the knees are we done talking about
this yet we always rely on clever puns
when we're nervous and we're starting to
run out of leg jokes let's go ahead and
get a leg up on the next episode we did
it again we used another leg joke to
deflect our feelings of embarrassment
seriously let's move on to the next one
romantic horsey back ride ah horseback
riding the perfect way to spend a
romantic afternoon with someone you love
but only when one of you isn't the horse
in this episode Beast Boy is trying to
woo Raven and asks if she would like to
go on a romantic horsey back ride with
him as the horse but she's not having
any of it Raven is known for putting the
smackdown on her male team Titan mates
whenever they crossed the line this time
is no different she reaches up with one
of her tentacles and snacks Beast Boy
right in his horse face the older
viewers may be grinning at this dirty
joke it gives the wrong impression that
guys should always be on the hunt and
girls should always be on guard against
their advances it gives power to the
phrase boys will be boys which girls and
women have definitely had enough of we
want to see an episode where Raven in
the game go to a women's March pink hats
and all there is so much oh Galena and
drooling over the teenage girl's body
parts it has us cringing it's definitely
inappropriate no horseback riding for us
Thanks and boys keep your tongues in
your mouths no one wants to see that
nice but we're going to go out in the
limb here and say that any cartoon
episode titled mr. butt is probably not
for kids in this Teen Titans go episode
Starfire sister Blackfyre touches Robin
working out in front of the TV there is
so much booty shaking and twerking going
on it is quite mesmerizing
it's no wonder black fire took notice
and then she makes an earmuffs worthy
comment that would make most adults
blush she asks Robin if anyone has ever
told him he has a nice butt
Robin is quite offended at being
objectified by her he even goes so far
as to call her a shameless harpy
she may have deserved that
least these Teen Titans are objectifying
both genders with inappropriate jokes
and now we feel it's time for an
important public service announcement
hey kids
commenting on one another's private body
parts is not OK
it diminishes the other person's Worth
and makes them feel self-conscious and
embarrassed try looking at a person in
the eyes while you're talking to them
and why don't we try to find other
activities like arts and crafts with
scissors oh okay
how about horseback riding nope they
ruined that activity too okay just don't
talk about each others butts is that too
much to ask
violence is cool kids in this episode
the Teen Titans make revenge fun by
plotting to get even with the snack
stealing squirrel if kids watch this
episode they might get the idea that
society is cool with violence as long as
it's funny cyborg actually says he
thought society was cool with violence
as long as people thought it was funny
we will admit Teen Titans go isn't the
first cartoon to send this message to
kids the show alludes to another cartoon
in which a hungry desert predator tries
to catch its cover prey but winds up
getting his brains bashed in with a
boulder to avoid getting sued by the
creators of Looney Tunes the cartoon
shows a day Niek act rather than wily
coyote and a purple fish with legs
rather than the roadrunner if we had to
guess we would say the teens heightens
creators got in trouble with the censors
for too much violence and they pointed
to these examples as an act of rebellion
it's a big no fair sign to the network
when the Teen Titans laugh the Looney
Tunes type show on TV
cyborg reminds them that they are
laughing at violence then cyborg punches
Robin in the face to see if he thinks
it's funny Robin doesn't laugh is that a
giraffe on your magazine or are you just
happy to see me everybody loves a cute
green boys singing about tofu we know
this and many other of Beast Boy songs
are quite popular with the fans and boy
does he love to sing about food so there
doesn't appear to be anything out of the
ordinary in this episode Beast Boy is
just hanging out waiting for his laundry
to be done eating tofu and playing video
games the part that isn't for kids
, dr. beast boy has eaten the piles of
tofu on the
he lays back and takes a drink from a
really long straw with nothing covering
his green body except for a magazine in
the shape of a tent ever heard the
expression pitching a tent and if that
wasn't suggestive enough the cover of
his zoo magazine has a long neck -
giraffe on it right where a similar
shaped body part would be on the other
side of the magazine for all the kids
out there who are talking about his legs
they are really pushing the envelope
with this one or a bunch of Randy
teenagers writing for the show or what
seriously we don't know how they get
away with some of the stuff word to the
wise Beast Boy maybe put some clothes on
before singing about hot dogs break the
law and I'll break your face when
Starfire hears Robin tell gizmo that if
he breaks the law he'll break his face
we know we're in for some more violence
and boy are we right this episode shows
a huge outbreak of aggressive fighting
Starfire
even hears when criminals bones breaking
as she crashes down on to the payment
cyborg keeps reportedly punching these
two guys who fall down but are forced to
stand back up by Beast Boy as an octopus
while Robin repeatedly stuffed some poor
dudes face into a bunch of green goop in
the garbage can to make matters worse
cyborg launches a bunch of missiles and
blows up these quote bad guys in an
explosion of smoke and fire cover your
eyes kids later when the Titans are
bragging about their reign of terror
Robin demonstrates a spine crack and
soft tissue destruction on a helpless
spatula to show what he did to the poor
guys he just bought this for a five-star
fire and prompts her to save more
peaceful and nonviolent solutions Robin
tells her there is nothing she can say
to make them give up kicking butt for
good but there you have it kids only
kick each others butts if you feel you
are in the right or not books may cause
sudden decapitation this Teen Titans go
episode starts out in a positive
direction it seems to be encouraging
kids to read books that's a pretty good
message right although if kids are
reading books they probably aren't
watching Cartoon Network maybe instead
they should scare the bejesus out of the
children by telling them that their
imaginations may come to life and try to
horribly
their knowledge seeking bodies it starts
out so sweet
cyborg was excited as he read about a
little wooden puppet Pinocchio but later
when they open a book that unleashes
their imaginations releasing
bad-tempered book characters to beat up
the Titans things go horribly wrong to
the nightmares kiddos it really Peaks
when the lovable childhood character
Pinocchio grips cyborgs cut off in a fit
of rage The Invisible Man has Beast Boy
in a headlock
while Robin is being chased by a
terrifying Benjamin Franklin who is
riding on a kite throwing lightning
bolts at him and repeatedly
electrocuting him meanwhile Starfire is
being chased by a fish shooting Pelican
if this doesn't discourage reading and
young kids we don't know what will
Cartoon Network's message is simple put
down the books and pick up the remote we
still can't help it though we love this
show breaking the law in the episode
where Robin has to take a test to get
his driver's license he has the
misfortune of being tested by an
instructor with an affinity for grand
larceny this driving instructor Rob's
banks casinos and jewelry stores and
makes Robin drive the getaway car as
police chase them and shoot at them this
is not exactly a good activity for young
viewers to watch Robin is sending the
message that it's acceptable to blindly
follow misguided authority figures and
commit criminal offences hey kids it's
okay to break the law if someone tells
you to do it nope not cool Teen Titans
Robin finally passes his driver's test
by driving incredibly recklessly and
endangering countless civilian lives we
hope no teenagers watch this before
their driving tests this was more than
just a Miss stop sign they really took
this to the next level lookout for sure
Robin is going to jail for this right No
whoa whoa whoa we think it would be best
to do some damage control to all you
younger viewers out there it's not cool
to destroy property still stuck or Drive
your car up a building just say no to
bad adults who claim to be driving
instructors and be sure to always use
your turn signals
under the influence in the episode
titled lazy Sunday Beast Boy and Cyborg
are maxing and relaxing on the couch
teams enison enough and Tala the spirit
of the couch appears in the form of a
psychedelic sunglass wearing cloud of
smoke puff-puff we know with the couch
spirit because it tells them listen to
the couch before imparting some wisdom
on how to be lazy you know because some
puffs of smoke cause extreme laziness if
you get our drift then Beast Boy and
Cyborg get the munchies
Starfire makes some chili and that is
the only thing that motivates these two
couch potatoes to get off the couch
while they are chowing down Robin takes
away their couch and replaces it with a
treadmill the gang starts working out
and getting healthy until the treadmill
spirit appears as that's right you
guessed it a big cloud of smoke this
inspires cyborg and Beast Boy to go on a
mission to get their couch back
motivated by the promise of tacos the
game gets the couch back and guess who
reappears yep the couch spirit cloud of
smoke which makes them all giggle we
think the writers of this episode were
under the influence of a certain
substance that is not suitable for
children what do you think then that's
it for 10 teen titans go episodes that
weren't for kids be sure to check out
our other videos on the things Channel
thanks for watching
[Music]